you did a blog post a while back I think
signs that you have blazing-hot material
yes so I'd love to hear that and then
I'd love to hear about the person who
thinks they have it
but then the industry isn't showing them
that right and the sort of the delusion
that made of all with that I mean right
it's helpful to know okay you know so
how you know if you have blazing hot
material your phone is ringing people
want to meet you they want to take you
out for lunch they want to take you to
dinner they want you to come over to the
barbecue they want to buy your material
or hire you to work on their projects
there's a buzz about you in town if you
don't have representation agents and
managers are sort of knocking on your
door everybody sort of kissing your butt
and saying how fabulous you are and you
feel really fabulous that's blazing hot
material when you get traction that's
how you know it's blazing hot and
there's people that aren't in LA they're
not in the business and they feel like I
could write a fantastic script let's say
and and it'll never get into the right
persons hands if and I'll never get
discovered if you have blazing hot
material that really will and even if
you know somebody who knows somebody who
knows somebody who can get your script
to somebody it's like six degrees of
separation if that material is blazing
hot you will be discovered absolutely
and what happens is if your material has
been out in the marketplace for three or
four months and nothing is happening you
can fool yourself by saying you know
what they just don't get it it didn't
get to the right person but the truth is
it's probably not ready yet it's it's
time to go back to the drawing board and
you wouldn't be the first person that
that had to happen for that happens to
most people because you don't come out
of the chute being perfect I think that
that's a lot of people's misconceptions
especially the screenwriters is my first
thing
CEL it's gonna be great again there's
the Mickey Fisher phenomenon
occasionally it happens but that's
really rare that's really rare
you